yeah he's just trying to adapt uh he's
not going to be in serious time trouble
yet but
40 minutes on one move that will haunt
him closer to move 40 later on yeah
that could be a problem as well getting
worrying for magnus carlsen fans
meanwhile napolite's
supporters they're gonna be uh licking
their lips they're gonna be thinking
okay magnus played some dodgy moves in
time trouble earlier in the match
especially game six
uh so they're gonna be hoping for that
again
wow he looks frozen yeah he looks frozen
and i
i don't think he's going to move yet
actually i think that might be a few
more minutes just judging by his body
language he's still unsure completely
unsure has he gone into that state
okay i was wrong
let's move oh oh nt this one we didn't
talk too much about i did mention
however that a queen move probably the
least ambitious approach
he gives a check with the queen and
there we go the evaluation bar back to
0.0
because black can block with the queen
and the queens would just come off and
that's not a good sign for players for
the fans who want a decisive result